in a detection this webinar is part of
the 2021 microbiology virtual week and i
am susie valdez of lab roots and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
militor sigma for more information about
millipore sigma go to
www.sigmaaldrich.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
that ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is also
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right hand corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits without
further ado i now present today's
speakers nicholas cavarelli and dr khan
sato both r d scientists at millipore
stigma for complete biography of our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen nicholas and
khan
welcome to both of you you may now begin
your presentation
hello everyone and welcome to today's
lab tools webinar
i'm nathan nee associate science editor
for the scientist
and i will be moderating our discussion
today our speakers nicholas cafarelli
and kan saito will discuss new rna
extraction and purification strategies
and how they enable reliable and
sensitive viral detection
we'd like our webinars to be interactive
we encourage you to send us your
questions or comments at any point
during the webinar and our speakers will
address these during the q a session
following the presentation
to ask a question simply click on the q
a tab
and type your query into the question
box located on the right side of your
screen
we will try to address as many of these
as we can during our q a session
this webinar will be archived on the
scientists website and we will send you
the link via email within a couple of
days
please note
that you will not be able to download
the presentation slides
i'd like to take this opportunity to
thank our webinar sponsor
milipor sigma is the u.s life science
business of merck kgaa darmstadt germany
our purpose is to solve the toughest
problems in life science by
collaborating with the global scientific
community
and through that we aim to accelerate
access to better health for people
everywhere
we provide scientists and engineers with
best-in-class lab materials technologies
and services
we have a broad portfolio of three
hundred thousand products an expanded
global footprint and are dedicated to
making research and biotech production
simpler faster
and safer
our sponsor has provided us with some
helpful resources related to today's
webinar and we have posted these in our
handout section located on the right
side of your screen
you can access and download these
documents at any time during the webinar
with that let me introduce our speakers
nicholas cafarelli has led the
development and commercialization
of various novel molecular biology and
protein mass spectrometry products
within r d at millipore sigma
he's previously worked at the american
red cross testing blood
testing human blood and plasma donations
and as an adjunct biology professor at
st louis community college
he holds a bachelor's degree from the
university of texas
in austin and a master's degree from
washington university in st louis where
he researched cell biology and virology
khan saito develops new research tools
for epigenomics and functional genomics
research as an r d scientist at
millipore sigma
he earned a phd in molecular biology
from tokyo medical and dental university
and conducted post-doctoral research in
jean-pierre kinnits laboratory at
harvard medical school and thomas
muslin's laboratory at burnham institute
for medical research
saito has researched protein and lipid
kinases phosphatases
and calcium signaling in immune cells
he has recently expanded his focus to
gene regulation
and epigenomics
let's just make sure everything is set
up properly
all right the floor is yours
all right so thank you all for joining
the call my name is nicholas caffarelli
i'm a r d scientist at millipour sigma
and i'll be giving the first part of
this presentation
before we get started since there may be
folks listening in from different parts
of the world today uh i think it's
important that we clarify that within
the united states and canada we are
known as milipor sigma uh however
everywhere else in the rest of the world
we are merck kgaa
okay so for my part of the talk i'm
going to begin by giving an introduction
on covet 19 which i'm sure we're all
very familiar with
followed by a little bit on sars kobe 2
biology this is the virus that causes
cobalt 19 and then a quick primer on the
qrt pcr technique afterwards i'll jump
into
geneloot which
is a kit that we offer for column-based
viral rna extraction and some data that
we've gotten with that kit
looking at starscopy ii
this will be followed by a overview of a
new product viral rna extraction buffer
which allows for
quick convenient lysis of virus such
that it is qrt pcr ready and then close
out with a summary of findings
so jumping right in
okay so as we all know covet 19 has been
around for a little over a year and a
half now and really represents a serious
global crisis
as of this month there have been over
170 million confirmed cases and more
than 3.7 million deaths reported
however fortunately vaccines are
becoming more accessible globally and it
is estimated that over 2 billion doses
have been administered thus far
um but nonetheless as you can see in the
figure on the right sars kobe 2 variants
with varying degrees of concern have
been emerging globally
with some of these
having been shown
to have characteristics such as higher
transmissibility more effective immune
evasion
and or more disease severity
i should point out as the authors note
that europe and the uk are over
represented in this map
not necessarily because the variant
originated there but because a lot of
sequencing is done there and so this is
often where new variants are first
identified
another significant cause of concern as
shown in the model on the bottom left of
this slide
is that current vaccines may be somewhat
less effective against emerging variants
as viral surface proteins mutate away
from neutralizing antibodies
so unless we're able to completely
eradicate this virus
all right so thank you all for joining
the call my name is nicholas cafarelli
i'm a r d scientist at millipore sig
and the whole particle then becomes
reassembled at the er golgi intermediate
complex
the result being in
particles that are trafficked to the
cell surface and exocytosed
and so the result of this is that you
have a viral particle that is fairly
dense in membrane and surface proteins
lipid bilayer which is host cell derived
and inside is
the genomic rna
which is tightly bound by this
nucleocapsid protein
the genome itself is fairly well
characterized
you have these protease derived proteins
that are believed to have a number of
functions
largely involved in viral particle
assembly
the polymerase and helicase
which help with
rna replication
and then these viral proteins the spike
envelope membrane and nucleocapsid
and all of these right here are going to
have abundant mrna within the host cell
so they serve as sort of attractive
targets
for mrna detection um
they're represented both as their own
individual mrnas
but they will also be on
strands of the entire genome
okay now i want to change gears a bit
and just touch on one step qrt pcr which
is the technique that we use for
detecting viral rna i think khan will go
into a little bit more detail here but i
just wanted to give a quick overview
and so the way this works is that for a
one step qrt pcr reaction
you put everything into one tube
so you'll have your template and
specific primers along with both
transcriptase and polymerase
and anything else you need for reactions
such as dntps buffer magnesium chloride
and
then both the reverse transcription and
the pcr are all built into your thermal
cycler program so you start with your
reverse transcription uh it's usually
around 44 degrees where the enzyme is
happiest
for about 15 or 30 minutes
this is perhaps followed by a hot start
activation and then you have your actual
qpcr in which you cycle through and
measure fluorescence at the end of each
cycle and so the result is that you'll
get
data sort of like what you see here on
the right
where
you have an amplification curve
that is exponential as you have doubling
of dna in your pcr reaction which then
eventually plateaus off as you exhaust
your
reaction reagents
you can then set a threshold a baseline
threshold
that
you want to put right around when again
the reaction starts to become
exponential
and where the amplification crosses this
threshold uh we designate that as the ct
value and so the ct value is
more or less a
quantitative indicator of how much
template you had to begin with or how
sensitive your reaction is so
uh if you have a low ct value and this
is all shifted to the left that means
your amplification started much earlier
so you had a lot more template a lot
more rna or dna in there to begin with
if your ct value is high
and this whole thing is shifted to the
right
then that means that you have a
significantly less template in there
if you don't have any amplification at
all that would be considered a negative
reaction so you don't have any template
detected
and so in this talk i'll be showing
qrtpcr data of sars kobe 2 rna so we
target the engine using
these two
cdc validated
primer probe sets and i use uh our
one step rtq pcr kit from the sigma
aldrive catalog so this is product
number qr200
and this comes with everything you need
uh it has the reverse transcriptase
magnesium chloride if you want to
supplement in which i do and pcr ready
mix that contains
attack buffer and dntps
so all you have to do is add your
primers and probe
qr200 also comes with
pcr buffer as a diluent and reference
die if you need either of those but i
don't use them
in these particular experiments
and so here on the right
you see a amplification curve of a
dilution series of synthetic sauroscopy
2 rna
and this is specifically targeting the
n2 gene
and so what you see is that i can detect
variably down to 10 copies consistently
down to 100 copies in my hands
but as you'll recall viral mrna is not
necessarily accessible for qpcr
rather it is encased in this
particle where you have your lipid
bilayer and your spike and other
membrane proteins
so in order to do qpcr you need to break
open the viral particle
and the way this is most commonly done
is using a column-based method where you
have for example a first lysis
that then involves binding to the column
washing out any leftover
lysis solution such that you can then
elute off clean purified rna
we recommend adding carrier rna at the
beginning
as that can help
with stability and yield especially if
you have small titers to begin with
and this
process was adapted
to our already existing rna mini prep
kit
by scientists in our organization kelly
wolf
and so you can find the protocol for
this online and i believe it's also
included
as one of the accessory materials for
this talk
so when developing this protocol
kelly used largely armored rna
but i want to try it out in my own hands
and so the experiments that you'll be
seeing here is with crosslink
inactivated sars kobe 2 which we get
from zeptometrics
and so the first thing i wanted to see
is if
this process is compatible in some
different backgrounds so i'm looking
here at saline particularly pbs
and then viral transport medium which is
uh sort of the most common medium for
nasopharyngeal swabs
when folks are doing
virus testing
so uh i spiked these crosslink
inactivated particles
into either of these mediums uh purified
with our
genolute miniprep kit so that we get
purified rna out of this and then i put
it onto our one step qrt pcr kit this is
qr200
and so we see
a good amplification at two different
concentrations uh
either a hundred thousand particles per
mil or two thousand particles per mil
as you would expect uh you get higher ct
value uh when you're putting less
particles on there
and i did this with both n1 and n2
primers and n2 is maybe a little bit
more sensitive
but overall
they both work well
and they work in both pbs and in viral
transport media
and so we see that
our
gen loop kits work well for prepping
viral mrna
i wanted to dive a little bit deeper
into this and see really how sensitive
this was
how low could we go
and so i did two subsequent experiments
uh diluting down virus based on the uh
amount reported by septometrics these
crosslink inactivated particles
and so i go down to about
125 or 250
virus per ml since i'm only loading 120
microliters of sample
that equates to 30 or 15 viral particles
being loaded
actually onto the column
and so what i see
uh between these two experiments is that
with n2
i'm able to get down to 250 virus per ml
or 30 virus per load
n1 quite not as sensitive
i get down to
60 virus particles being detected
but still this is quite sensitive
and so you see here that this is fairly
linear
and really if we wanted to increase
sensitivity um one thing that you could
do is increase the sample load assuming
that you have a good amount of sample
because you are essentially
concentrating on the column um so if
let's say you do a 300 microliter sample
load 50 microliter aleutian then you
would get six fold concentration and
that would potentially be quite
sensitive
um but for our purposes we demonstrated
that we could get pretty low so we were
happy with this data
but we do realize that column-based
approaches are not without their
drawbacks
so even though it's generally easy and
straightforward it does require a
centrifugation
or manifold vacuum manifold
so it can be a little bit time consuming
um
and more importantly
these kits can often suffer from supply
chain shortages and we saw that this was
really an issue
sort of as the pandemic got underway um
and it was a serious bottleneck
for a lot of virus detection
and so
we endeavored to come up with an
alternative
and so
earlier this year we launched this
product which was developed in the fall
of 2020
which is our viral rna extraction buffer
and so the way this works is
it's a 4x solution so you take
say for example six microliters of your
sample uh and you can add two
microliters of viral rna extraction
buffer
and all it is is a five minute room
temperature incubation in which you lyse
open viral particles
such that they are directly ready for
qrt pcr
so this can actually even be performed
in your
qpcr
strip or plate ready to go on the
machine
one thing we did find is that if you're
using saliva uh you get best results
centrifuging uh so and then taking the
supernatant so that you don't have sort
of debris and particles getting in the
way of your
reaction and so
this product
has worked well
we find that
again all you need is a five-minute
incubation um
it's a crude prep but there's no cleanup
required
and we have some data demonstrating that
it's compatible both with qrt pcr and
lamp
uh which will show
and that also it's compatible uh with a
number of different backgrounds so
things like saline viral transport media
and saliva
so in developing viral rna extraction
buffer we wanted to make sure that it
was compatible with a number of
different backgrounds
so in order to
demonstrate this what we're showing here
is i took
cross-linking activated star scope ii
particles again from zeptometrics and
spiked them into either saline saliva
or one of these viral transport mediums
lysed with
a viral rna extraction buffer product
number brd100
this was again five minute room
temperature incubation uh such that the
result is a crude
rna prep uh so we're not purifying
anything out
but the rna is now accessible
uh by the qrt qrtpcr
reaction components and so we put this
again with
qro200 our one step qrtpcr kit
so if you look at our data in saline
again we did a dilution series
of particles per mil and we see as you
would expect that
as you have less virus your ct value
increases
but we are able to get down to
uh
1500 particles per mil
saliva not quite as sensitive so saliva
is kind of tricky to work with it's
highly variable between different people
sometimes you'll have something that's
really
easy and kind of clear other times you
might find saliva from someone that's
viscous
full of debris
so we wanted to test it across different
individuals so here in this figure we
show saliva from
four individuals uh all healthy
and so here we see that it's not quite
as sensitive as saline
so we're detecting down to fifty
thousand
uh viral particles per ml
however this is
relative to the viral load that you
might see in a patient still
pretty low
and we see that actually for three out
of four people
we probably could have gone considerably
further
but one of these had particularly
difficult saliva and so we didn't detect
at 2.5
times 10 to the fourth or 25 000 so this
is
sort of where we say our sensitivity
goes down to
similarly we did test it in a number of
other mediums so again viral transport
media
other commonly used
storage mediums for nasopharyngeal swab
such as eagles or amy's
and here you see that
it works in all of these
we're looking at
a thousand
bottle particles per mil
or sorry ten thousand viral particles
per mil
and if you don't treat it you don't get
any signal in these backgrounds but if
you do treat with viral rna extraction
buffer
then
it appears
so
this demonstrates that
in order to detect at least this amount
in these mediums you do require
at least some kind of lysis
so this was all very encouraging and
we're very happy to see that our viral
rna extraction buffer seems to work well
across different mediums
and we were curious sort of how it
compared to similar approaches
that uh like viral rna extraction buffer
don't rely on column based purification
and so the closest thing that's out
there that's sort of most commonly used
uh from the literature
is this protein sk with heating method
so
in this experiment i replicated sort of
one of these commonly used protocols
where i add pro k
vortex for a minute heat and then
centrifuge
and then to the same samples i treated
them with viral rna extraction buffer
so this is uh one times ten to the five
cross link and activated particles
starts to be two particles
uh and again this is in saliva from
four different healthy individuals
and so what we see here is on the right
a representative amplification
is that we get amplification uh much
earlier
and so we have much stronger signal in
our hands using viral rna extraction
buffer
the pro k plus heat method worked but um
we didn't really get ct value up until
the
high 30s or low 40s
and then if you use neither method you
don't get any amplification
so this data demonstrates again that in
our hands uh viral rna extraction buffer
does give
lower ct values so it's a
um sort of more robust technique and
that uh also it's a little bit more
uniform uh in the output so you can see
here that the data points are clustered
a little bit closer together so we
believe that this is a little bit more
reliable than using pro k with heat for
virus detection by qpcr
so
the last piece of data that i'll show
today is the only one that doesn't use
qrt pcr as a readout
this is work that was done by tony anema
an r d scientist who set out to
demonstrate that
viral rna extraction buffer is
compatible with
lamp or loop mediated isothermal
amplification
and so this is a pretty neat technique
uh it uses
a
strand and complementary strand that
form these sort of dumbbell shapes which
can then
amplify off of each other
and what's neat about this technique is
that it's isothermal so you don't
actually have to do thermal cycling
you just maintain an elevated
temperature where lamp enzymes are
happiest so i believe this was done at
65 degrees
and
you can then
get your readout
so for this experiment uh tony used the
same crosslink and activated particles
that i had been using and he likes these
with viral rna extraction buffer bre 100
so that he has crude rna
but instead of going on to qpcr
he went on to a
lamp assay kit a color metric lamp assay
kit that's commercially available from
neb
and so what you see from tony's data is
that as a control
he just looked at first water and
synthetic viral rna
so this is already exposed rna not
particles
and you can hopefully see here that a
negative result has this sort of purple
color
a positive result so if rna is detected
is this yellow color and these are
both done in the absence of viral rna
extraction buffer
so the next control that you see here to
the right
is
using the same conditions but in the
presence of viral rna extraction buffer
so again synthetic model rna
is detected by this color metric lamp
assay it gives this yellow readout
um if it's if there's no template then
you have this uh negative readout so
this kind of pink or purple
color metric result
so this tells us that viral rna
extraction buffer doesn't interfere
with the lab assay itself
and then finally
within sort of the experimental group
uh if
tony runs
viral particles in saliva
through the lamp assay but without viral
rna extraction buffer
um
a lot of the rna is inaccessible and so
you get a negative result even though
there are viral particles in here
however if you lyse first with viral rna
extraction buffer then you do get your
positive result
so this indicated to us
that viral rna extraction buffer is
compatible with lamp and
can be paired with lamp
and and specifically can
help you get results if the lamp assay
by itself is not enough so a little bit
of a sensitivity boost
on this lamp assay readout
okay so to summarize
today we looked at two different
approaches
for
making rna viral rna accessible for
detection by qpcr or by lamp
the first of these
a mini prep using our genolute
mrna miniprep kit
we found worked well
its advantages are that it's highly
sensitive
the material can be concentrated which
would even allow for more sensitivity
and because you're getting a pure clean
prep
this is
likely better for long-term storage
long-term storage say in the freezer
and so with this approach
again because it's very sensitive we
detect
down to 500 virus per ml in viral
transport media
however
if you want something that maybe isn't
quite as sensitive but is a quick
convenient easy
amenable to throughput
we offer this new viral rna extraction
buffer
so again this is a five minute room
temperature incubation
um no
column based cleanup
and we tested it across various sample
types we want to show that it can be
used
broadly in different backgrounds
so detecting
as low as
1500 virus per million saline
or 50 000 in saliva
or 10 000 in transport mediums
so with that i'll hand it off to khan
and i'll take any questions at the very
end um and i want to thank everyone for
listening thank
you
hello
i'm kan saito and i'm an rnd scientist
at maple sigma
and in the next section i'll talk about
the principles of one-step articular
assays
the differences between the kits that we
supply
and the evaluation of the kits for such
corporate virus detection
this figure shows the source code's
genome
source code is a positive strand rna
virus and is about thirty thousand
nucleotides in length
at the five frame end
there are two large orfs
all found a and all from b which cover
over two-thirds of the gene and encodes
non-structural proteins
the last third of the genome encodes
four structural proteins
namely it's the spike surface
glycoprotein
e the envelope protein
and
the membrane glycoprotein and the
and the nuclear capacity phosphoprotein
because the genome is a single strand
rna
mutations can be introduced during the
replication process
in this figure the lines represent the
number of mutations
found in
4400 thousand of the genomes
within these mutations the
s-protein mutations are especially
concerning
since these mutant proteins can increase
bindings to cell surface ac2 receptors
during hostile entry
which increase their transmissibility
and severity of the disease
variant that carry s-protein mutations
has been identified and classified as
variant of concern
here is a list of some of the notable
variants that are classified
variants of concern voc or billions of
interest voi by the usc
b117 variant that was first detected in
the uk is one of the most widely spread
variants
this variant carries the e484k
mutation
and its transmission is about 50 percent
higher
similar balance that includes
transmissibility were identified like
the
b1351 from south africa p1 from brazil
b1429 from california in the u.s
and recently
the b1672
brilliant was detected in india
this brand carries
l452r and e484q
mutations
and
significant reduction in neutralization
by antibodies generated during previous
infection
or vaccination were reported with this
variant
although this variant is currently
categorized as voi it is already majorly
concerning
now let's go back to pcl detection of
the thus called virus
when the kobet 19 pandemic began
artificial tests were the first to be
developed
and they remain the primary tool used
for diagnosis
the u.s and other countries developed
acid targeted at the end protein gene
because of the abundance of the enzyme
subgeneric sensor rna
artificial assays targeted the enzyme
could theoretically achieve enhanced
diagnostic sensitivity
so previously developed mass curve and
size of assays also targeted the enzyme
this figure shows the sequence of the
enzyme
as you can see several countries
developed their assays targeting this
gene
the uscdc developed n1 and two assets at
these locations
here are sequences of the primers and
tacoma probes for the n1 and ends the
assay
next
i will explain the principles of dual
ability probe assay or the tukman
provision
the tachman probe consists of
fluorophore currently attached to the
five frame end of the origin nucleotide
probe
and quencher at the three prime end
the quenching molecule quenches the
fluorescence emitted by the flow for
pure flat
in the pcr reaction the primers and the
probe are needed to their specific
target sequences
the polymerase extends the primer and
synthesize the nussent strand
when the polymerase reaches at tacoma
probe
its endogenous fiber nucleus
activity creeps the probe
separating the dye from the quantum
thus leaving the quenching effect
and allowing fluorescence of the
fluorophore
now i'll explain the principles of the
one-step rdqpt allocates
in one step rtq cell
reverse transmission or cdn synthesis
and qp cell are carried out in a single
tube
by employing sequence specific primers
for the
amplification of the specific target
the kit performance are dependent on
three components
namely device transcriptase rna
inhibitor
hot start dna polymerase
ibus transcriptase is one of the most
important components of the kit
moronine urine leukemia virus reverse
transcriptase
mmlt is used in most one-step rtqp
circuits
in the past few decades
the enzyme evolved through genetic
modifications
the rns minus point mutation was the
most common mutation
which includes reverse transcriptase
sound activity and
improves sound stability
in addition to the point mutation
multiple some stable mutations have been
discovered
here is the list of
one step rtq visual kit we supply
the kick q start kit and app script kit
employ mlb rt with both rns mass
mutation and some stable mutations
and the rt temperatures are increased to
48 to 55 degree celsius
the next important component is the rnas
inhibitor
rnases can be introduced from samples
primers or probes
this figure shows one-step articulation
assets with and without the rns
inhibitor
as you can see there are five city
differences between the assays
meaning
they differ by a factor of about 100
finally the efficiency of the hot start
dna polymerase is a critical factor
there are two different hotstar dna
polymerases
namely antibody mediated and chemically
modified
in general
antibody mediated dna polymerases can
activate in less than 2 minutes at 94
degrees celsius
compared to chemically modified enzymes
which take
seven to ten minutes at 95 degree
celsius
all rt cup shell kits
we supply use antibody antibody-mediated
dna polymerases
here is the summary of the factors that
affect the performance of one step rtq
pcr
genetic modification of mmlb evas
transcriptase
rns h plus or minus
some stable mutations which affect the
rt temperature
quality of mmd evas transcriptase
quality of rns inhibitor
the efficiency
of torque dna polymerase
finally
the buffer compositions including the
magnesium
chloride concentrations and the dntp
concentrations
when the kovit 19 pandemic began we
evaluated one step rtq pcr kits which we
supply with the usc dc n1 and n2 assets
though those kits are researches only
using infidel synthesized source code's
genome rna
we evaluated the one-step articulate
using the following criteria
no abnormalities in
the amplification curves
the r square values and slopes from the
standard curves are within range
no amplification from
non-template control
ntc samples
which is uh important to avoid
false positive results
the ct number
from
a sample of 100 copies
smaller is better
the minimum copy numbers that kit
amplify
lower is better
we evaluated these one step rtqsp
circuit with anyone and and its assets
and we confirmed that all amplification
curves were normal and that the r square
values and slopes from the standard
curves
are within range
and
there was no amplification from ntc
samples with these kids
this table shows
city values from 100 copy samples
and the lowest copy numbers amplified
for both n1 and assays
and
from these results
all kids shows
decent efficiency and sensitivity
detecting such called rna
between the lowest copy detected is
beating
single digit to
lowest highest number would be 100
sigmoid hqr0200 quantitative artificial
leading mix
kits shows a lowest city number from 100
copy samples for both environment and
assets the newer sigma audit q start kit
shows overall
best performance
like lower ct value and the lowest
number of copy to be detected
for both n1 and rc
and
sigma already observed two kit
forwards
finally we test the compatibility of one
step rtq shell kits with vre 100
by rna extraction buffer
the
qr0200
kick q-start
and cover kit as well as some official
stock pass kits shows excellent
comfortability with vre 100
to summarize
in response to the community's need for
sales called specific reasons
we have evaluated one step rtqp circuits
for south carolina target detection for
research use only
all one-step rtq circuits which we
supply demonstrated excellent
performance detecting the subscribe to
rna
our newest kick cue start one step probe
rdqp cell ready mix kit
which utilizes the most innovative
technologies
performs best overall
and the quality quantitative artificial
ready mix kit
qr0200 also performed very well in the
evaluation
the qr0200
qqq start and cover kit as well as some
fish attack basket exhibit perfect
compatibility with vre 100 viral rna
extraction buffer
thank you for listening and i will be
happy to take questions after the
acknowledgement
thank you
so
thank you very much for those
presentations
as a reminder to our audience you may
submit your questions to our speakers
using the q a tab at any time
our audience has already submitted
several questions so let's begin our q a
session
and for the first question
i will address this to nicholas first
and can after nicholas answers if you
have anything to add please feel free to
to chime in
i our first question is
are the
[Music]
are the viral rna extraction buffers or
the qpcr kits
can they be used for diagnostic purposes
uh
yeah so nicholas here um
so
these are as indicated research use only
grade products so our organization we're
not
we don't develop diagnostics or ivd
grade products
that being said if a lab
wanted to incorporate any of these
products into a diagnostic workflow
it would be
their responsibility to
validate it within that workflow
and to make sure that they are
compliant with any
applicable regulatory agencies
um
and you know we'd be happy to help as
best we can towards that um but yes
ultimately uh we developed them research
grade uh any use and diagnostic behind
beyond that would be
the responsibility of the customer or of
the
testing lab to validate
you nicholas khan do you have anything
to add to that or
it's a
durian under
each country's regulations
so
we cannot comment for this
our next question and this one i will
start with yukon uh what sort of sample
contaminants could lead to amplification
failure
this can be uh uh
uh various things uh you can think uh
some uh sounds are contaminated to
microbiome biomes or uh like uh if you
uh contaminate some of the blood content
like hemoglobin those things can inhibit
so uh from that point of view uh the uh
the kids like
crown based verification that's nick
nick shows being a dude
could be the
best way to purify
rna for or visual example
thank you khan
nicholas for our next question we have a
several comments and um several quick
questions from our audience asking about
some clarification for
the experimental parameters so
i suppose we'll just get kind of get
started
with
those uh one question asks whether or
not you tested the viral rna extraction
buffer using uh sample stored in
inactivated transport media itm
uh so the answer is no um there's a
whole lot of different storage and
transport mediums out there so that's
not one that we've gotten to uh yet but
it's a you know it's a good question a
good suggestion um so
i think it's something that we should
look at and
uh hopefully we'll have some data for
you in the near future on that it's a
good question
thank you very much uh next for
either nicholas or khan were any of the
experiments that
you did where you presented the data in
this presentation were any of them done
using pooled samples
and potentially pooled samples
where individual samples were processed
in different ways
i didn't do anything like that um
you know i think in theory it's
something that you could try uh
but it's not something that we tested in
particular or that i tested in
particular
yeah it's possible to to the test for
some of the uh for example and maybe
lanza and ngs not a pcr
but we didn't test
thank you and the last question along
this kind of line of questioning uh were
any of the samples obtained using
nasopharyngeal swabs
so the answer is no
you know again because we are
doing
sort of research use only products and
we don't have a
bsl
setup for appropriate bsl setup at our
facility to handle np swabs um
we tried to sort of from a research
standpoint replicate that
as best as we could using these
cross-linking activated particles and
transport medium as you might see in an
mp swab
um i will say that you know we are
looking for
uh
clinical
collaborators who are trying to
uh
see how this works in in mp swabs um so
if that's something that
your lab is uh
interested in and you're working with np
swabs and you'd like to try out uh vre
100
you know please feel free to reach out
and
we'll be happy to send you a sample and
work with you
thank you nicholas uh so along that kind
of line of thinking do you anticipate
any issues with
samples that come from different sources
or have different processing
or possibly more heterogeneous samples
such as wastewater for example
uh
yeah we haven't looked at waste water um
certainly i think
you know i think the the big takeaway
here again is if uh
if you anticipate a sort of very messy
mixture a very
complex sample
um then for a very sensitive reliable
approach
uh
you know we would recommend using a
column-based method
um
if however you want a quick convenient
screening tool
um
that's you know perhaps a little bit
cheaper and automatable uh then you know
we encourage you to try vre 100 and
see how it works out for your particular
needs
thank you very much uh next question
will be for khan
does
trisol rna isolation have any positive
or negative effects on
uh the ability to to detect viral rna
actually these are
i think tested by nick nichols before
yeah so i did use uh
trisol as a positive control um
and it works you know trisol is a very
reliable method that's been around
for a long time
uh
and so i i have used trisol extraction
going into rna
into qpcr
and as long as you
uh
you know after your precipitation do the
full wash and everything it should work
uh
just fine um but that was uh i think in
a relatively clean sample um
so so i'm not an expert on trisol i
think it has a lot to do with uh
with what exactly your sample type is
and and what other possible
contaminants could be in there that
would interfere with qpcr if you have a
very clean sample
um it should work for qptr but uh you
know not all samples are clean
another question for nick is there a
maximum amount of time that the sample
can be incubated with the viral rna
extraction buffer
um so we
we tested it up to 30 minutes
maybe 30 or 40
and didn't see any decrease in activity
um
we didn't
see a need to test beyond that because
you know we figured people prefer faster
than slower um
but if if
you wanted to try that you know we would
say you know have the shorter incubation
has a control
uh and you could try storing it in the
fridge um
but at least up to 30 minutes
you're definitely safe
beyond that i would say unknown
thank you dick uh
cut
do the q rt pcr kits and extraction
puffer do they work with multiplex qrt
pcr as well
yes uh potentially it works for
multiplex qp but uh the detailed
um
detailed conditions are
quite very uh based on the uh
combination of the targets and you need
to
experiment i test the uh
combination
if you want to do the
multiplex
and i believe we have time for one more
question and uh this one i will
open up to both of you but i'll starting
with nicholas
can you detect other viruses in addition
to stars cov2 using the extraction
buffer genolute
or these kits
yeah that's a good question um
so we
with jennaloot uh we've used uh you know
similar
inactivated particles
and we've seen that with genolute we can
extract and detect rna from
flubi
and flu a
with vre 100
we have seen
that we can
lyse and detect rna from flu b
we had a little bit of trouble with flu
a uh so we're still playing around with
that um
you know it's unclear if there is uh
specifically a physiological difference
with the uh composition of fluid that
makes it particularly difficult
but
that's sort of still ongoing
we hope to test
rsv soon
so this is you know primarily for rna
viruses
we also have a little bit of data with
um
aav which is a dna virus and it did seem
to work uh
give a little bit of a boost in
sensitivity using bre-100
that being said you know the as was seen
from the presentation really the
majority of the data is on sars kobe 2
that we have
khan would you have anything to add
oh no
unfortunately that is all the time that
we have for today
if you have any further questions please
consider reaching out to our speakers
directly
their emails are shown on the screen
as a reminder the webinar will be
archived on the scientists website
and you will receive an email notifying
you when the on-demand version becomes
available for viewing
i would like to thank everyone who took
the time to join us today and
particularly those of you who shared
your questions and comments
on behalf of the scientist i'd like to
thank our speakers nicholas cafarelli
and khan saito
as well as our mil as well as our
sponsor milipor sigma
thank you everyone and have a pleasant
day